en ce moment c'est la saison des
asperges j'adore ce légume qu'elle soit
blanche ouverte
le problème c'est l'odeur que dégage nos
urines quand on a mangé des asperges
ça sent pas bon c'est à cause de leur
composition
elles contiennent un acide qualifié très
justement d'aspar à guzik qui au moment
de la digestion se transforme en
composés soufrés les mêmes que l'on
retrouve dans l'oeuf pourri ou dans les
sécrétions du putois un animal réputé
pour la mauvaise odeur qu'il dégage ce
qui est étonnant aussi avec les asperges
c'est la rapidité avec laquelle ces
composés agissent c'est parce que
l'aspect convient aussi beaucoup de
sodium et d'eau ce qui rend cet aliment
diurétique
sitôt ingurgité sitôt évacuer un peu
comme ces capsules de les confiner si
vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
vous pouvez aussi revoir les précédentes
vidéos gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour et pour être sûr de ne rater
aucune et bien abonnez vous et activer
la petite cloche à demain et n'oubliez
pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien faut que je vous
laisse